we've talked about how Donald Trump has
very quickly damaged the reputation of
the US around the world and justice
first six months in office but this is
also a factor with world diplomats who
increasingly see our president is really
sort of a laughingstock a bunch of top
ranking European officials spoke to
BuzzFeed on the condition of anonymity
and they said that their chief concerns
with Trump are his unpredictable Twitter
usage as well as his generally erratic
behavior and they also described the
President as quote something of a
laughingstock at these international
gatherings and that's so funny because
when we when we see Trump show up at the
g20 and other events and he acts like a
little kid in a really weird way the
diplomats and the other world leaders
are noticing which shouldn't really
surprise us and as one official
described it to BuzzFeed diplomats
considered Trump's vocabulary to be
limited to so few words and phrases that
they play a sort of word bingo when
Trump talks everything is great very
very great tremendous whatever can you
imagine
Trump goes up there and he says it's
going to be huge it's going to be big
league tremendous this I promise you and
then Angela Merkel from the back of the
room stands up and yells bingo you have
the bingo you have the handshake game
yeah you have posturing for who's going
to be in front and center of the picture
like a lot of games of the mountain
agrees or Montenegrin I'm not exactly
sure what to say Prime Minister I
believe it was shoved aside by Trump who
popped up there and a show that he is
the guy who gets to be at the front of
the pictures at the g20 the president's
an international joke and this matches
polling of European 79% of European
citizens have no confidence in Trump
according to a recent Pew Research study
and it seems European diplomats are sort
of in line with that exact same
sentiment one official added in speaking
to BuzzFeed he won't even want to listen
to the argument or have a debate he is
obsessed with Obama pretty astute
diplomats over in Europe uh they picked
up on Trump's vocabulary they picked up
on the fact that Trump just seems
fixated on criticizing Barack Obama and
slamming the things that Obama did and
how he's better than Obama but the
saddest part about all of this when I
read about it is that the Trump is don't
care
about this they'll hear about this and
they'll say good I know I will get
emails from the handful of totally out
there trumpets who email me pretty
regularly they'll say David good for
Donald Trump the excuse me the fact that
other diplomats see him this way it's
because he's doing such great things for
Americans and that's who he said he was
going to help of course European
diplomats aren't going to like him
because he's so great for us I think
this is a big deal though because if you
remember back during the George W Bush
administration perhaps his biggest
failure was worsening the American image
and Europe and around the world and that
one called the Iraq war and because well
at heart because of the Iraq war yeah
and Obama's biggest success might have
been improving on that image and Trump
has toured that down in six seven months
in record time in record time sometimes
I do wonder whether Trump's bluster is
mostly when he's like at a friendly
rally or maybe on Twitter for example he
slammed Obama on Twitter endlessly in a
really vile and disrespectful manner
then he met with him after winning the
election and it's all yes mr. president
terrific meeting President Obama is a
good man he's got very very good ideas
go to a rally ban Muslims until we
figure out what the hell is going on
blah blah blah then he goes to Saudi
Arabia he's holding hands with the royal
family yes sir mr. Prince never heard of
radical terror mr. Prince yep no sir yes
sir absolutely it there is some degree
to which Trump is like the he when he
has a medium of interference he is way
more aggressive than when he actually
has to show up and talk to people most
of whom are his intellectual superiors
right I think you know the lack of
support in Europe has to do with the
fact that they're a lot more left-wing
than we are here in America yeah and it
reminds me of that Economist poll that
looked at how different countries would
vote in the u.s. election for this
passed roundly drafting and every
country listed there would have gone for
Hillary Clinton none of this is
surprising right like there's no
outliers here that say well you should
really consider whether Europe really
thinks Trump is a joke like every
indication at every point is suggested
that oh and one more example by the way
of when Trump does like the big man
stuff on Twitter and at the rallies but
then he completely seems to get cocked
even the entire max
we'll pay for the wall stuff if you look
at that leaked transcript when talk
about Trump spoke to the Mexican
President Trump was worried that if the
Mexican president keeps talking about
how they're not going to pay for the
wall that it's going to be really bad
for the for the PR aspect for Trump he
seems completely unconcerned with the
actual immigration implications just
please mr. president please don't talk
publicly about how you're not going to
pay for the wall it's really really not
good for me it's totally pathetic the
guy just he claims to be this great
negotiator but he gets out negotiated
every time he claims to be such an alpha
male - there was such a beta move I
think it was direct totally beta totally
beta today's program is made possible in
part by Blue Sky binary forex trading
major major space millions of traders
trading Forex around the world 80% of
them lose money you need to understand
basic proper money management rules you
need to understand how to avoid getting
emotional in your trading you need to
have the appropriate base of knowledge
for forex trading and blue sky binaries
education course provides exactly that
blue sky binary is a leading financial
education and tech company they focus on
FX and they've got senior traders with
real trading experience offering a
structured and self-paced course and
that includes video on-demand it
includes online tests one-to-one
education sessions access to their
community of traders to exchange
knowledge and experience and my viewers
and listeners can register right now at
blue sky binary.com / David to get a
one-week free trial which includes not
only access to the platform and training
materials but also a session with a
senior trader to get you up to speed on
the basics of forex trading continue as
long as you want for $99.99 a month
after that stop cancel resume as you
wish you can get the one-week free trial
at blue sky binary.com / David